and Brian the wet weather certainly
affecting the roads there were several
fatal crashes today alone as you can
take a look here at the map this is
where each one of them happened the
first early this morning 4 a.m along the
2 15. State Police say man was simply
going too fast for the conditions
causing him to lose control before being
killed but the most recent happening
right here at Di and Jones earlier
tonight Metro Police say the driver of a
Nissan pickup lost control crashed into
a car which then caused a chain reaction
the pickup crossed the median hit
another car head on and a female
passenger in that car died six others
had to be transported to the hospital
officers say impairment though was not a
factor